are we
back I think if it happens again I'm
just going to stream it straight to
Youtube that's dumb I don't know what
the heck is happening with
this should we should I just change the
bit rate
oh
jeez what the heck is wrong with the
Internet well I can nuke the
uh the bit rate for for a little
hello I think it's the internet just
being unstable let me just nuke the bit
rate a little
okay let me know if that looks terrible
or
not super obnoxious with the uh the
Internet it's like you get a third of
what you pay for
if it disconnects again I'm just going
to stream directly to
YouTube since that's where most of the
viewers
are
so levels and such right
see okay if it go it looks like the
stream is stable if it goes down again
though I'm going to just do it to
weird um at least for the day Divided We
[Music]
Stand is this crowd strike's fault sure
let's blame crowd
strike why I have crowd strike when you
have when you can have blink strike
right
so total XP
is
240 640
3,200,000
[Music]
900,000
23 UH
uh
Def and
level
self uh
so now we have a function to get the
level we have XP table
implemented we do player. level one
XP equal
zero
player and how much xp do you get for a
player kill
experience
okay so plus 7.69
player
kill return
plus int player. XP
over
7.69 I'm not going to be able to get all
of the uh all of these like the XP in
Dota is very complicated they're all
bounties and stuff but I want to at
least get like Baseline values to be
reasonable hey
well have you seen the project
project let's see if it runs at the
moment uh let's
see yeah it does here's a
I haven't tried it in human playable
mode for a while
but it's got five
classes okay I got to fix this stuff but
it's human playable and it's actually
kind of fun um
yeah it's going to be obviously really
stripped down but I figured it would be
really cool if we could do open like we
could do mini DOTA at a million frames
uh a million frames per second that
sounds like a good thing for RL to have
are you just stopping by here or did I
miss a
message I thought I sent you a reply and
then I didn't hear
good jealous that you basically get to
do Game Dev all
day I
mean it's hard Game Dev like you it's
Game Dev if you had to design your games
to be a thousand times faster than uh
they actually are designed to be
so I mean there's
that what's this project this project is
uh
little under 1100 lines of scon right
now started this on
Monday probably some of this is garbage
though we can probably get this back
down to like 900 or
so that's how I got into programming in
the first
place didn't everybody do games of some
sort I think I wrote Minecraft mods
really really bad Minecraft
mods
uh Rite
mod CRA is this like a
thing yeah I made some really shitty
Minecraft mods
XP other experience
sources neutral creeps each have unique
base value
penalty what you do to optimize
this um well part of it is the
design of what logic I allow to be runed
um but this is like right now this is
just random scon that I haven't bothered
to check but the whole like per tick
Loop will run in uh it will run in pure
C when I'm done with it so combine
designing the game in a way that doesn't
require all that many expensive State
updates with the thing running in pure C
and it turns out purec is
fast this is going to be mixed
continuous and discreet the uh player
controller is
continuous and then there's some discret
buttons
expect do the lane creeps not level up
and give you more
XP what are you doing to minimize State
updates um
many
things I guess
like not doing object-oriented
programming I guess is a big one like
this is the
entity The Entity is a struct in tily
packed contiguous memory so you've
essentially got an entity component
system
um and the entity component system
mirrors all the data is mirrored to
python so there are zero copy
so you can do your whole sim without
doing any uh any like big copies of data
there are zero dynamic memory
allocations all the memory that you need
for this is just
preal um other than like instant stuff
but you're not you're never actually
having to explicitly Malik any
memory um yeah lots of stuff like that I
don't know a bunch of techniques I've
picked up over the course of doing simd
in the past few months
it's kind of all the same techniques as
I used in the big like the fancy
slither.io style
enf but uh you know it's a bit more than
that we've got some pointer Shenanigans
not too
much this is like a good example of
shitty unoptimized code that doesn't
matter because it's in in it and then
lower down there's like way more
optimized stuff you reset creeps not
realic Etc yeah yeah yeah stuff like
that
I mean just not having stuff be in
really gross classes makes a big
difference as well
um
the entities are like 100
bytes you have maybe like a couple
hundred
entities so like everything is very
tightly packed in
memory it's very nice
does the experience not go
up on Lane creeps I would assume it does
doesn't
it
oh here it
does every seven and a half minutes they
gain a permanent upgrade to attack and
health damage and an increase to their
bounties this is pretty easy to
implement
you weren't at open AI when uh when dodo
was a thing right you joined like
shortly thereafter didn't
you some of them look right here this
gets XP the range creep gets an XP
Bounty the other ones look like they
don't right
after oh man that's when I was I was
interning there when they were building
it and it was the just the coolest
freaking project like if I could pick
any project in AI that I wish had gotten
way way way more you know Dev on it it's
DOTA DOTA was just the best damn thing
in RL it was so
cool we'll see how much time I want to
spend on this project but like we could
potentially get something that looks not
as not that good but we could get
something that looks pretty darn good
sure I don't know how much I want to do
I don't want to do item
builds uh opening I I remember they
scripted the item builds
we'll
see this is the kind of [ __ ] cursor
could help you implement quite a bit
then
optimize I'm going to be real hard to
sell
on AI That's that aggressive with my
code
um I've got super Maven here super Maven
is really nice it has a very long
context
you
know it's very
fast
did they make oh yeah yeah they did make
a documentary about the DOTA RL stuff
yeah they
did there's so many gems in that paper
as well like you can basically deduce
half of modern RL just from the DOTA
paper like literally half of I think
that half of the RL papers that were
written like if you just fully read the
DOTA paper you would see that they did
like those papers did not have to be
written it was so ahead of its time and
nobody read the full thing because it's
a really long
manuscript like almost nobody read
it happy to help on this would be really
fun oh no wherever you're you going to
get the source code will well to be fair
it's in this gross any config Branch at
the moment I'm going to try to merge all
this stuff to Dev over the
weekend
um how are you doing on compute
resources for this
stuff because I have a few machines we
might want to run some crazy sweeps on
it we'll
see I think I'm going to make it we'll
get it really fast
though I'll show you
so I've shown you the cluster haven't I
here this is where all the code is for
this
stuff it's just in any config Now goal
is going to be to merge it up to Dev
this
weekend uh and I currently have
bookmarked for
this these two boxes here are bookmarked
for it I don't know if I'm going to be
able to get a million steps per second
train but definitely 3 or 400 ,000
will'll be able to get on
this architectures are going to be a
little bit of a
pain but yeah you want to hop in sure
hop
in more than
marrier wouldn't it be cool if you had a
code stream where uh you get enough
viewers and you're just committing stuff
in real time that like your viewers are
submitting you bug fix PRS in real
time that'd be the
dream you'll have to forgive some of the
garbage code I've written in here to get
it fast on done fast
though the skills are really simple like
these are all the skills here
they're just like some combination of
attack AOE heals like pull and push
stuff like
that they feel pretty fun to play
actually let me see if I can get this to
to run real quick
because it would be pretty cool to show
off what's wrong with this health bar
Max
Health oh I need to just set the max
health of something I
guess hold
on neutral spawn
spawn Max
Health Mana
red I'm importing my sub modules for
four hours
never use get sub
modules oops got to
what's wrong with my uh my health
bars something's getting Max Health set
too something's definitely getting its
Max Health set
wrong
uh well I could also just
Nan wait I actually don't know how to
test for Nan and python
uh I can just check if Max health is
zero
two so it'll have a really long health
bar
this one as
well Mana
bar okay here it
works here's the game
I've not played it in a
while seven
is the heck is
seven oh hold on
uh
[Music]
noxious we're going to have to do asset
map something's going to have to be
uh
seven yeah we'll do this for now it'll
just have the same texture as a creep
forgot to update the neutral
texture okay so here we're at the
fountain let boost
out here are our puffers those are
neutrals over
there blink
strike and the AOE
we will lead the puffers on to
Victory and this is where the uh the
Nexus is going to be
so yay so is draw a bar in
Python no this is RB uh RB is like a
single file C library that's in Python
but like we're not going to render this
thing at train time they're going to get
local
state even opening I five is local
state can we blink strike uhoh stunned
strike oh
jeez never
mind how are you handling movement uh at
the moment movement is just straight
line pathing so it's very basic
um a viewer suggested that I could
pre-compute AAR pathing which
um I can actually pre-compute pathing
and it'll be
fine these guys are just straight line
pathing to waypoints though at the
moment so we'll replace that with AAR
pathing to waypoints uh but we're going
to have to pre-compute it you do not
want to run AAR uh in the Sim it's too
expensive for you know know ultra high
perf
stuff these are neutrals do they aggro
to me yes they do aggro to
me do these guys aggro yep they aggro
these are neutrals
oop it ass seems that they don't die
when they hit zero HP so that's a
bug bummer you can't do path we will be
able to we can just pre-compute
it uh viewer mentioned that today so you
can totally all you will have to do is
you'll have to just pre-compute uh op
optimal path from every cell to every
near every way point and there are not
that many way points
so we're going to basically have the
same thing as optimal pathing to way
points at
go puffers why are you following me oh
that's
weird I don't know why they're following
me obviously some stuff that has to be
fixed to
health it's pretty fun though this is an
assassin character it has it has an AOE
that only works on minions or can only
be targeted on on
minions uh it has a blink strike ability
that teleports and does a ton of damage
and it also has a a move a channeled
move
skill obviously map is missing any
forest or Vision or stuff like that
can't use the blink strike on this guy
that's funny there we
go you should uncenter
camera um currently I have a movement
via mouse cursor position instead of
Click once I make movement via uh click
then I can do that
definitely some bugs to fix oop neutral
clipped me could use some animations as
well but I think the main things that we
need uh we need like leveling
we need to have like reasonable curves
for stuff for
balance uh reasonable like damage curves
and
stuff
and probably pathing would be another
big
one I don't know why these guys are
stuck
now I think that somehow I got oh yeah
yeah I I remember so there's uh there's
some like memory bound issue at the
moment that's why the towers aren't
showing up uh something is writing is
overwriting my team
ID how do I make the
map the map is readed from uh
DOTA and the spawn positions of the
Creeps and stuff are readed from
DOTA so this is just straight up the
DOTA map
this is what the DOTA map looks like
with no trees just like the
immortal how did you reverse engineer is
that public there's a repo that had some
scripts in
it um they had some scripts and uh it
collect a lot of the data and I just
like grabbed the pieces of the data out
that I need and integrated them with
syon so we've got a nice big yaml file
that has uh it's got the map it's
got uh it has the way points so like
when the creeps path they have a set of
way points that go along their
Lanes so we have those and then there a
few other things as well like the
neutral spawn positions and
such the straight line pathing isn't
that bad though for the neutrals to be
honest they can get stuck on their way
back sometimes um but the straight line
pathing for neutrals like they just run
after
you and then they run back to their
camp and the minion waves fight
we can help
them and then they just keep
pathing and there's no Nexus objective
yet and that's out of
memory
okay last hitting yeah we will uh we
have to add the leveling and XP system
but we'll just award we'll just award XP
on last
hit not doing gold since we're not doing
the item system
um item systems really really
so
uhoh hold
see you
well let me know if you want to hop in
on this it'll be
fun let's figure out if we can get the
um before we do the XP bug because I'm
going to stream this for
another maybe hour or so it's Friday um
want to be well well rested tomorrow's
long C
day
so let's do
um let's figure out what is
so spawn neutral here you give it idx
plus numb agents towers and
neutral that's not right is
it
wait 72
right yeah
obviously
so well that's fine I have
72 minions right
num
neutrals entities is Agents creeps
neutrals
towers and then we do agents creeps
neutrals Towers
right so cre creep idx
is creep idx percentum creep spawn
creep
wave gives
you ah so this is wrong right
here this is just plus numb agents
right you don't add the number of towers
to this because it's agents creeps
neutrals
Towers I don't know if this is enough to
fix it
though this is Agents towers and
creeps oh wait no no you don't do plus
Towers either here
this is Agents plus
creeps and then spawn Tower
is let's
see idx plus num agents
plus plus num neutral okay let's see if
this fixes
it we get our Towers back in our tower
defense game
and we have our Towers
back so that was the bug
they're going to get merked because
they're right next to the tower Yep this
full wave is going to go
through uh they're going
to die to the tower yep die to the
tower so minor issues this is actually
pretty solid
I think we're going to record this as
the uh the demo real
solid what are the green Twitchy things
those are neutrals we have neutral camps
now that's
it demo for Twitter
K MOA is massive online battle arena
like
cool it's 524 let's at least get some
levels in let's get levels added to the
game a few other things
maybe so
really what we need is we just need all
the spawn functions to add this
stuff appropriately to the agents
need let's get some reasonable XP values
for Stuff
right type is equal to entity
player player equals XP for
player if a Target taret type is entity
player
house target.
XP
kill something like
this and
all we have to do here is add the
neutral spawn
neutral
XP on
kill equals let's just give it an
average
value give it a average value
here neutral creeps give
you what is the
uh average of all
these like a medium Camp
maybe 14 17 28 20 30 looks about right
to
me how much is that compared to a
creep less than uh a single creep
is that
right these only give
you neutrals really don't give you that
much
xp I guess in uh in Dota there're
supposed to be more like
bonus is that Vim editor you're using
it's
neovim it's pretty vanilla though my
config is on uh the puffer tank GitHub
puffer a/ puffer tank it's basically
just a color scheme uh super Maven for
code complete and SEI for some extra uh
python highlights that's
it color scheme is my
own my taste for Aesthetics stopped
changing at age 14
so it's basically Tron
reasonable 35
XP then the
minions will give it
60 okay
so now let's see if we we can actually
level up with
this we'll just have to add a overhead
like
level
Mo what do we have this
as entity player which is zero
wanted + 8
y plus two what on Earth is
this
garbage Yus
height wait what
why minus
height minus 2 right y
minus 2 *
height minus it should be minus
4 plus
20 white
8 I know we'll just guess we'll wing it
with
that nice uh hold on I just saw your
message need to uncover the chat nice in
University I had a semester with Vim
only black and white nothing
fancy that's nuts where did you attend
uh my bachelor's is from Stanford and my
PhD is from MIT I just graduated two
two-ish months ago
okay this still works let's
do render mode
human okay
well that was weird
um this is way too big so let's change
this to size
14 come to
Brazil why come to
Brazil I know you guys got B good
barbecue there but
like
Okay so we've got the tower
oop let's not run into a
tower oh this is super fast mode because
I have yeah the rendering skipping
still level
one I think we need to add an XP tracker
bar
right Raw Bar
I don't know we're just going to draw
this bar I guess
right Yus height - 2
Yus height -
RG B
uh hold on 0
255 not too familiar with mobas but
don't Pros click at crazy speeds or
something would be cool to see The Click
distribution from a trained agent yes uh
so one I currently don't have the
movement map to click to move it's just
drag to move which is different and two
agent aren't going to be able to click
that's the one big limitation um they
get like a joystick for movement and
then they get like a select essentially
over targets it's kind of like if you
had a joystick and a numpad instead that
is somewhat a limitation of RL but also
it's just going to make the project way
less of a pain in the ass for me and
like you know this is not what I intend
to be doing for the next three months so
the goal here is to like make something
that is mini MOBA learn some cool stuff
is a useful environment and then move on
to the next environment
yeah well this is going to be
difficult um
this I'm current in undergrad at Ohio
State CSC only two semesters remaining
I'm ready to be
finished any advice on getting into the
game development industry
poof
um well I don't work in the game
development industry first of all this
is like a reinforcement learning project
that just happens to be game
gamified
um but from what I know from
people um game development industry is
tough so you'd better really really like
it because the hours are long and the
pay is not as good as big software
engineering
um but
uh it's not really any different as far
as I'm aware from recruiting anywhere
else um
um you know you've got to line up lots
of different interviews you can look it
depends if you want to go to bigger you
know bigger Studios or to
Indie to Indie places right I will say
Game Dev is an awesome way to learn a
whole bunch of stuff about building
things like building games is hard I'd
say building games is much harder on
average than building like big Tech
[ __ ] products
might not be the best person to ask
though I am mostly a
researcher who solo builds lots of wonky
stuff these days I am a full-time RL
see level one
what
oh why is
okay here we are I don't know why it's
Drawing level one down there but
uh you
know we get some XP off of somebody
XP so the XP does actually
work does it reset when you die
fast
and why is this drawing the level text
twice is what I would like to
Jank but whatever this will fix it for
now
yep okay so you've got
level this is moving a more reasonable
speed you got speed
bam 240 XP for the
wave and then there's blink
strike we can blink strike again
nope link strike
[Music]
again and we're not going to get XP for
the tower yet because I didn't add any
let's go figure out Tower
XP
Tower XP on kill for the towers is going
to be listed in the wiki right
XP well Towers have to give XP in the
one I'm doing because there's no gold
reward
do gold okay
so Tower DOTA how much gold do these
things give it's a lot isn't it
ads my God these wiks are just so add
infested it's not even
gold the tier uh two three and four
Towers all do the same amount of DPS
which is enough to kill you at level one
in about three seconds and this one's
about 5
Seconds what is an OSS RL
xorcist I'm an open source Dev I work on
reinforcement learning
and the field of really of uh
reinforcement learning is really
cursed so my goal is to make it not
cursed fun way to say that is I'm an RL
cheek Towers really don't do that much
damage I mean the level ones do a ton of
damage before uh
Bounty what is this
Sigma Grand unreliable gold
not that much
gold oh wait last
hit this is across okay so they give a
lot of gold so these need to give a lot
of
XP
um 900 so this is the tier one is like
500 how much gold does a minion give
melee range like
20 let's say 30 on
average that's almost 20 creeps worth
of
gold they give more gold or XP they give
more shoot so that's a lot of XP then
that you'd
want well but wait let me see I have to
be careful not to unbalance this
because it might not even need to
give to give XP honestly because like
you get the tower kill right which is an
objective but I guess it gives an a
better incentive to push in multiple
Lanes right yeah it gives more of an
incentive to push in multiple lanes
because yeah cuz otherwise it's bad cuz
your minions pushing okay
tower at like level like what four six
and what level are Towers taken
at I don't know we ask uh grock I've got
this here hey shitty llm uh what level
are T1
Towers usually taken in Dota
Mark but what
level heroes
when they take them
xp600
XP 2400
XP 3200 XP
as for the damage
values uh we're going to have to balance
all those anyway so we'll do we'll do
damage values
separately and because stuff isn't
balanced and I can take a tower right
now I should be able to use that to test
the leveling system
wait s. level there we go got to update
the level
okay so
whoop
here assassin class with the movement
boost feels really really
good and 1100 XP and I jumped to level
four
cool so this works
now I should be able to hit uh neutral
camps right
oops I hit neutral camps now with the my
Q yeah we can hit neutral camps but they
don't
die
that how much HP are neutrals supposed
to
have and Lane creeps for that matter
Health
300 we'll average these two together so
250 125 425 Health maybe call it 450
I think the neutrals are even stronger
aren't
they we need to increase stats over time
of
um which is one of these is like a
reasonable
[Music]
Centaur this guy what do you
have 350 Health that's not that
much are they all low
Health ogre
Bruiser 800 health
health we'll give him
500 we'll give him
500 and how much health do
these well we also have to figure out
how we're going to have him attack and
stuff
we still have everything channeling
attacks right
now this should be more reasonable at
the very
least so I should be able to hit the
neutrals but not immediately kill them
at level one
fun I think it's basically almost time
to to like decide how I'm going to fix
the attacks and
stuff because right now everything is
just a
channel so 554
I'm going to
um I'm going to go use the restroom I'm
going to come back I'm going to do like
one or two more things on this and we'll
call tonight I think we're going to
do we're going to think a little bit
about whether it's reasonable to uh to
make the attacks a little
bit more standard which would then also
make it easier to add like projectiles
or stuff so we'll see about that be
right
okay last little bit to close out the
stream I we've made very good progress
this week we made very good progress
this
week it's pretty darn cool to see how
much you can do just like man hacking on
a
thing I'm going to be here another half
hour or so
welcome I'll be here another half
hour I
generally I guarantee you I'm not going
early because I have anything planned
it's just uh Friday I try to do stuff a
little earlier so I can get some rest
get to sleep and uh prepare for Saturday
which is non-stream day code 12 hours 14
hours
depends not necessarily on this project
though I might do a little bit on this
but if I do stuff on this it's only
going to be stuff that you'll be happy
as off stream anyways it'll just be like
clean up refactor test some stuff make
sure uh you know try to get it like
stable enough to put in the dev Branch
stuff like
that I'd like to merge things into Dev
so that uh you know people who want to
hop on and start contributing to puffer
with maybe seen the stream uh can have a
little bit of an easier time doing that
oh if you just got here by the way let
me show you what you've uh what we've
done
today what is it with you and me going
to
neutral camps full
map start of a basic leveling
system proper pathing at least more
reasonable
pathing you can see these Minions
fighting the to
here it's pretty cool to
watch it's pretty cool to
watch I think it's every 30 seconds or
minute or whatever it is it might be
minute we might have to make it every 30
seconds for the minion
waves oh yeah we should actually
calculate the uh the movement speed
right based on the DOTA
they took a tower they took the tier one
in
mid so
solid movement speed is basically should
take 30 seconds for Mid creeps to get to
the center of the map well let's go
calculate
it we go to
calculated there are a few things we
actually we got to decide on
so I'm going to do the math first and
then we'll uh and then I'll tell you
what I'm on
about let me put my camera back here
this is where I like
it
um
being 30 seconds for S side Lanes yeah
so move speed is 325
right and the DOTA Map
size is 17,000
units so
177,000 divide
by the movement rate of
325 is a factor of
523 so that's how long it takes in
seconds for them to walk across the
whole one way to the other not diagonals
which is about what you
said so if I do 128 which is our Map
size divide by
2.4 units per
second so now now here's the big
question and this is where things get
um a bit more
difficult though technically I can
smooth animations it's just a little
harder to do that
um I need to decide on the internal tick
rate of the
game so basically I need to decide how
often the server is going to actually
update
the higher I set that value the more
precise everything is but the more data
you're wasting for reinforcement
learning I was thinking of setting a
tick rate of
five which would give you a movement
speed of about 0. five for creeps
can you not scale the map size such the
move speed ends up being an why does it
need to be an
integer it's not the issue is not about
the integer
representation the issue is
fundamentally I can scale the move rate
the only thing I need to figure out is
the tick rate of the
server which I think like five is a good
tick rate for a
server it's the number of updates per
second that the server is going to
do let me see what that would turn out
to be
B I think agent speed of
0.5 if it's the same as the creep speed
that is which I don't think it
now I'm going to use I don't know
Lena how fast is
Lena oh they're basically the same as
uh as creeps
okay so we can just leave that as 0.5
then that's fine I didn't realize
that and then how often do the creep
waves
spawn 30
seconds so it's five ticks per second
time 30 seconds
is
right spawn the creep waves at
150 then how often do we spawn
neutrals going say every four
minutes 600
um yes but this is a global cool down so
I'm not it's not a minute after you kill
them it's just every four minutes I'm
respawning stuff because I was
lazy I can't make this one to one with
DOTA because then I'm just
reimplementing all of DOTA right
we're already at 1100 lines it'll be
down to 900 by the time I refactor it
but still like this is close to the code
size that I'm comfortable with for this
project so there you go this is real
time
apparently basically when they get to
Mid the next wave
yeah they're getting there
every well wait maybe I'm maybe I'm
rendering it at the wrong rate
Towers should be shooting creeps I'll
check one
so uh no this is rendering at the
correct rate
there this is how fast the game is
supposed to run
so basically right as the the side Lanes
as they uh the waves crash the next wave
is spawning
waves seem to be just growing let's see
if uh if the towers are shooting creeps
or
see is it just me or is the red team
always super crack down mid possible
right now they're pretty even though
aren't
they here I'll move my camera so you can
see the bottom
Lane oops
the white team has agents that are
getting stuck on the bottom Lane you can
see that will be fixed by
pathing so I think that they're losing a
little bit of the advantage by going one
by one even though this is their safe
Lane
you know what's going to be a lot more
fun than this
though what's going to be a lot more fun
than this is when I just delete the
it what do we think about the full send
game
it looks way cooler doesn't it
some minor pathing
issues especially around the river
looks like red might have a chance of
taking a tower here maybe takes
middle if it cannot get
stuck not
really still pretty evenly balanced
Sim I don't you can't run DOTA this fast
can you like you can't like run the like
the Bots this fast even if you wanted to
could
you I don't know how fast their uh their
timer goes and by the way we've done
zero and I mean zero optimization on
this
environment
um I said it's going to be a million
frames per second and it's going to be a
million frames per second now that is
divided by the number of Agents which is
10 10 players so 100,000 of these frames
as you're seeing them but still it's
going to be very fast
super
fun okay
um there's some scaling stuff we're
going to have to do
is this
rendering the full screen every frame or
just the parts that change that was R
what the thing that you just saw was
rendering the full
screen
um in fact it was upsampling as
well but like that's not even that's not
the limit it's going to
be open CV is the limit there because
open CV is really stupid and slow and is
rendering one frame at a time
um yeah this will be nice and fast you
don't worry about that we'll do an
optimization stream at some
point oh no no no I I see what you mean
no it's not the underlying simulation is
still rendering every tick it's still
running every tick
the one thing I don't know how I'm going
to get around is
um this target FPS here technically has
to be
five which is not going to be
fun
so I you can run it faster
but you're playing do at Double speed
so right here what you're seeing this is
what the this is the speed at which the
agents are going to be playing the
game they're getting every like every
frame you see here is essentially what
they're getting they're not going to get
the rendered version of it but they're
going to get something like it
they're going to have access to only
what is
nearby so I'm going to just double the
uh the render speed of this game for
human play so it's not choppy even
though that's going to be really
fast and maybe we'll do some frame and
turp
after but you're essentially you get to
play do at Double speed
FPS because it's 10 FPS um it's locked
to 10 FPS it's not
choppy that will some somewhat Lim the
strategic game play since they can't
play the
map well they can
like you don't know what's on the other
side of the map without being there
right oh I see what you mean not having
the mini
map well technically depending on how
you code the model um you could make it
so that you you have access to all of
your teammates Vision as well not to the
minion Vision minion vision would be
harder to implement
knowledge of nonvisible things yeah they
can learn that over
time right now it's locked to every four
minutes the neutrals just full respawn
every four minutes right
now you'd have to learn to time that
you'd have to learn to do a full clear
and then come back right at four
minutes well you say they'll learn that
but like DOTA is also kind of the
hardest RL project that's ever been
accomplished so
trivial I said we were going to talk
about the attack timers how do we do
attack timers
do they have access to the game timer to
even know when it's at 4
minutes not by default I can add a timer
I can add that into the observations
very easily if I want to
though I should probably add a uh a
default like a basic attack cool down
right e
the basic attacks at the moment are
channeled so they just they apply every
single frame and they do a very small
amount of damage so your health bar like
like drains instead of going down by
chunks I think we can just give
everything a basic attack timer
uh these guys have a 1 second base
attack
time what's like someone like Lena
have 1.6
so they're even slower
eight we get rid of this garbage that
saves us some
lines and this garbage as well so we
just saved ourselves like 30
lines what's the attack interval of a
tower
0.9 which we can't do so we're going to
round that to
1.0 which is five
damage is
and we'll give these guys a basic attack
timer different tier of towers do
different damage oh yeah they absolutely
do what do we do for neutrals basic
attack
um one second as well we didn't even do
Minions that wait spawn
creep these guys have basic attack but
we didn't do their
damage where's creep
do 100
there attack range attack
[Music]
damage uh they
do 19 to 23 21 to
26 we're going to call
that we're going to say that they do 22
damage for
now and these guys are just going to be
like creeps I
22 now we got to implement the attack
cool downs I guess
timer oh we didn't Implement did we
implement the player
re path
creep
uh this is a basic
attack creep
oops Target
D so that they don't jump on top of you
completely this is
neutral
AI it's going to be a basic
attack low
dist dist is going to be the
L2 if dist is less than
two cre path
neutral okay oops
there we
go so and now we only thing we got to do
is the tower
attack we got a tower attack and then
that's I'm going to make sure this works
and I'm going to go get off for the
night uh let's
see
AOE well this we don't want to
do we need to get do a nearest Target
function
I think we can actually just do like
this cuz the attack is going to handle
it for us
right m these checks are expensive
though so we'll do it like
I'm probably just writing tons of bugs
here at this point hold on creep this is
not creep this is
just going to finish this up here guys
um if you have not starred puffer lib on
GitHub please do helps me out a whole
ton this is all open source Dev it's
really all I ask
hard to say I think I got to go get next
to a tower
it's skipping if the target is on a
different team thank
you this is why I need to stop at this
hour because I'm going to uh
start just writing shitty
stuff like we've got 200 lines of code
in this program that should not be
there at least
200 if I really tried I could probably
knock 300 off of this
me so I'm assuming the cooldowns are not
getting
it's still going to be very difficult to
add animations though because I'll
basically I'm going to have to add like
IDs to all the targets and
stuff so if I want projectiles I can had
like in place
animations yep there you go the tower
just chunked me for
uh do I need animations that not really
just to make it like more visually nice
right
what if I go near these
guys how quickly do they murk
me they don't seem to murk me very
quickly at
all I guess the neutrals don't have the
update status code
they oh is it update it's not update
status though right it's update cool
downs and Tower even the tower AI so
this is
Jank this is going to need a big
refactor are creeps willing to Target
players on another team
yeah creeps will Target players on
another
team they'll Target Towers on the other
team and creeps on the other team and
players on the other
team not
neutrals you guys are going to just
chill here and not hit
me yeah that what going to
do
412 y'all get one hit on me is that how
it
works 346
HP how's that happen and they sto moving
as well
well this is player so this should be
neutral um this is also player this
should be
creep I got to stop working on this
soon
Tower I don't know if the conditional
was soft it could
be I'm going to get this to a point
where I can push the code and uh if
anybody wants to open
PRS they're more than
welcome just at me and like let me
know you get credited in uh in the
puffer lib on the puffer lib site if you
uh submit anything more than like you
know a couple bug like a typo fixes or
like you know whatever
go hello
puffers you appear
stuck you also appear very strong
yeah looks like a stopping point it does
doesn't it but I can't tell if they're
just stuck on each other
stuck do you have getting started
docks um unless I forgot any
dependencies which like you might have
to pip install rib for this
renderer
um there's getting started docks on
puffer lib but you should just be able
like clone it you know pip install Dash
e
dot there's also a Docker container for
it if you want
that okay they're definitely stuck like
you
said I don't know what I changed that
would have gotten them stuck though oh
no they're not stuck that's
weird I guess maybe they're stuck on
each other
yeah well they look stuck
here oh I know what it is actually I
know exactly what I
are the puffers
stuck are your puffers
stuck nope they appear very happily
fighting now
H this is like this character feels
really good this one it feels really
good you can like burst away from
stuff you can blink strike into
stuff they're not stuck now they're good
all right so we fixed all the all the
really obvious stuff let's Commit
This
MOA
test see
okay so this is now pushed um I will
show you where this is briefly and then
I will take off for now
so first of all we've got puffer ai.
github.io which has some info on puffer
lib and what's going on in
here there's the Discord which is puffer
uh discord.gg puffer it's a good way to
get to uh contact me when I'm off
stream of course there's my Twitter you
can add me there as
well we've got puffer which by the way
if anybody wants to Star this we're one
off of
650 that's
nice growth has been amazing so thank
you for the
support any config is the current Branch
I'm going to try very hard over the
weekend to like get this synced up with
the dev Branch but uh you can open PRS
to to the in the meantime it'll still be
you know all everything I can still
merge from there no
worries any
config there's a simple setup file you
can pip install Dash e dot or whatever
you might have to also pip install rayb
if you want the human rendered version
uh and then it is in puffer
lib
environments ocean and MOA this is where
all the source code lives uh now if you
want to run the same demo that I'm
running you've got the commands right
here it's the same as all the other
commands and if this is too hard to
remember
DH tons of parameters and you can see
there's a dashn parameter so you can do
no
d-nv mooba DH
and we're still missing stuff so we
didn't add no render mode mode that
stuff mode eval
render mode by default you get RGB
array but you can also do das Das render
mode human I do it this
way we get the high level
overview and uh you know there's some
prams in the clean puff RL file that
tell you how long that runs
for you can get your little Sim like
this boom
this thing is
sweet I'm very happy with it
not sure if this is you but I
will where's this thing oh yeah we've
got uh we've got some fun puffer
folks perfect well I'm going to go uh
get some food decompress a bit and get
ready for Dev tomorrow we're going to
see how much Headway I can make over
there over the weekend lots and lots of
stuff to do I think it's mostly going to
be trying to get the dev Branch synced
up this new config and stuff um if you
guys want to try stuff for
this uh you know you can add PRS here
most of these are in fact merged they're
just by like people I know personally so
I've like manually merged in changes
because like they were to dirty branches
or whatever but uh you know stuff does
get
merged so thank you all and uh I will
probably be back on Monday for stream
see you